بطوله خليجي بنسختها الخامسه والعشرين
التي تقام في البصره حولت متحف المدينه
للاثار الى واحد من اهم الاماكن التي
تقصدها الجماهير ووسائل الاعلام الخارجيه
التي دخلت المدينه باعداد وصلت الى اكثر
من 35,000 عام
في بطوله خليجي 25 الى جانب ان نحن همم
نغطي البطوله من الجانب الرياضي وايضا
احنا كان دورنا ايضا نبرز الحضاره
الاسلاميه وايضا تاريخيه اللي تمتلكها
العراق
هذا المتحف الذي يقع على شط العرب يضم
قطعا اثريه تعود الى الحقب السومريه
والبابليه اصولا الى العصر العباسي
بتواجهه ثقافيه وحضاريه للبصره للتعريف
بالتاريخها وعراقتها
2200 قطعه اثريه كل القطع اللي موجوده في
متعه البصر الحضاري هي قطع اثريه اصليه
تعود لفترات متعدده متحف البصره الحضاري
يتوافد اليه العديد من الضيوف
اشقائنا العرب
الخليجيين
اضافه الى شناشيلها واسواقها التراثيه
وكوريها يحرس مشجعوا الفرق المشاركه في
بطوله الخليج على زياره متحف البصره
للاثار للتعرف بشكل اكبر على حضاره بلاد
الرافدين وان كان ذلك عبر بوابه كره القدم
من متحف البصره منتظر رشيد العربيه